what is your favorite Disney movie well
it's not here
beauty in the beasts my favorite Disney
movie is the Little Mermaid came out
when I was 9 years old
a crab started singing a Caribbean
Calypso tune and my life was never the
same my favorite Disney character splash
princess slash kick butt heroin was
Mulan from a young age she totally broke
a gender norm and I thought that was so
cool my favorite Disney Princess is
Cinderella what do you look for in a
soul mate I like adventure oh so very
happy I don't like making plans so you
need to be adventurous if you wanna hang
with me I look for humor I'm going to go
with kindness everything else fades
secretly
you think your enemies are envious of
I'm gonna say my passion my
industriousness and call me a lot of
things but lazy is none of them I don't
have enemies what is happily ever after
I am perhaps the adventures continue I
mean I've seen into the woods there's no
such thing as happily ever after life
just keeps it going there's no act -
there's no act 3 you just keep in [ __ ]
evolving oh there's one for that the
adventure continues I'll click that
adventure continues
I knew I was getting Ariel you're a
dreamer who's always thinking of next
big step in your life somebody think you
set your sights too high but your
friends know you are capable of anything
Wow I got Jasmine daring and adventurous
you are considered the daredevil your
group enjoy having fun taking risks and
living life to the fullest
you also are incredibly handsome and you
smell it nice here's the thing I was
looking at these princesses and then I
thought you know what I am just I've got
I got a pic jasmine at the top of this
thing but then I thought wait that's too
cheesy because I'd be a doting dad
because my daughter's name is Jasmine so
I'm not gonna do it and then as such the
universe works I wound up being Jasmine
so I'm very happy about that